le pass and i ter purement et simplement
supprimée en catalogne la région
espagnole le juge inefficace face à
omicron et mettra fin à cette mesure dès
demain matin dans certains lieux une
décision qui semble diviser la
population les détails avec clémentine
laurent à barcelone
à partir de ce vendredi les catalans
pourront aller au restaurant à plus de
10 en jeu d'occupation et puis surtout
sans pas ce sanitaires le gouvernement
régional a décidé d'abandonner le passe
dans la vie quotidienne et ce quelques
jours seulement après avoir levé la
quasi totalité des autres mesures qui
étaient en vigueur alors il faut
rappeler que la catalogne est l'une des
régions les plus touchées par la sixième
vague de kobe 19 dans le pays et les
autorités avaient imposé à la
mi-décembre de très nombreuses
restrictions comparé aux autres régions
d'espagne mais depuis plus d'une semaine
le gouvernement catalan a décidé
d'assouplir ces dernières mesures alors
la semaine dernière il a tout d'abord
levé le couvre-feu et puis à partir de
ce vendredi eh bien les catalans
n'auront plus de limitations aux
rassemblements sociaux il n'y aura plus
non plus de jauge d'occupation dans les
lieux publics comme privés et puis enfin
c'est la fin du pass sanitaires et sur
ce dernier point les barcelonais sont
plutôt partagés et mais pas les cépages
factor
ça me semble parfait pour moi ces
restrictions et est une atteinte aux
droits des gens oui il y à des mesures
préventives à prendre en termes de santé
mais ce n'est pas possible de retirer
des libertés aux gens on peut se tenir à
distance porter le masque ne pas faire
de fait ou de rassemblement mais ce que
je ne comprends pas c'est qu'ils
disaient tu ne peux pas être dans un
restaurant fermé mais il permettait des
concerts avec un certain public ou du
théâtre
le pass annie terme semble être une
chose importante il faut que tout le
monde puisse certifier qu'il est
vaccinée au final le vaccin c'est
important bien sûr une grande partie de
la population espagnole et déjà
vaccinées
la grande majorité alors ça ne me paraît
pas si mal avoir retiré les restrictions
on devrait quand même le maintenir un
peu plus longtemps quand il n'y aura
plus autant d'incidence après un temps
si les choses s'améliorent au pourrait
le retirer mais pas le retirer comme ça
joyeusement d'un jour à l'autre
la raison de ces assouplissements c'est
que la sixième vague ralenti en
catalogne selon le gouvernement même si
le taux d'incidence est toujours élevé
dans la région et bien le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations lui ralenti et
puis surtout les experts estiment que
l'application du pass thani terre n'a
pas réellement prouvé son efficacité
pour limiter le virus comme l'expliqué
serge dual band sow épidémiologistes
[Musique]
c'est
la principale raison que l'on évoqué au
début pour l'imposer été principalement
éviter la propagation du virus
lorsqu'une personne infectée entre dans
un endroit relativement fermé cependant
le fait que le variant omicron touche
aussi des vaccinés fait perdre de la
valeur au passage du ter donc dans ce
sens on peut considérer qu'il ne
remplissait pas son devoir
à noter qu'ici en catalogne le pass
sanitaire n'est pas vaccinale comme en
france c'est à dire que pour l'obtenir
ici il faut être vaccinés ou avoir eu
locaux vides il y a moins de trois mois
ou bien avoir obtenu un test négatif il
faut aussi ajouter que même si le past
and i terre et est obligatoire ici et
bien certains établissements ne le
demandez pas comme ici à barcelone une
partie des restaurants ne vérifiez pas
les passes sanitaires de leurs clients
mais toutes les mesures n'ont pas été
levées pour autant ici en catalogne le
masque reste d'ailleurs obligatoire dans
toute l'espagne à ce jour et puis les
discothèques de catalogne reste
également fermés